Dean Koch told me one time
that occasionally they get calls to
The college of Optical Science
from the comminity
about getting a new pair
of glasses.
Oh wow.
Yeah, so how did you
even know what optical science was?
Well, my father is a software
developer so when I came
to U of A I decided to study
electrical engineering,
and it was more of a passive
decision just because my dad
is a software engineer so
it makes sense that I could
also do software. But then
when I was a freshman I started
reading an industrial journal,
and I became convinced
that optics in electronics
was the future of electronics.
How did you get interested
in science?
I liked Chemistry in high school,
which sounds a little weird,
but I did like chemistry and math.
You know, my mom always had
a can-do attitude, you know?
Do whatever you want.
So, she showed me schools in
Philly, Boston, and we had to
stop at Syracuse, that's where
she went, and D.C., and I
got into Penn early decision
so I went to Penn.
And then once you got
to Penn, the whole world was
open to you, how did you
keep going along this
engineering pathway?
Mentors. Definitely mentors.
I had high school students,
undergrads, medical students,
grad students, post-docs, and
it seems like everybody learns
from one level above them,
you know, what's the next thing like?
What about the Girls
who code program?
How did that all get started?
Well the Women in Science
and Engineering Program here,
at the University of Arizona,
has a chapter of which I am
program coordinator and lead facilitator,
and we use the girls who code
nationally provided curriculum to
teach computer science to
middle-school and high-school
age girls around Tucson.
Mentorship and what you're doing
with the girls who code
you're already giving back
and it's really important
for the next wave.
I think that sometimes
it can be difficult if you're
not involved in research to
find like graduation students,
for undergraduates to find
graduate students, or even just
mentors in the community would
be cool too, like people who
work in engineering
So you can see what it's like
in the real world.
How can I apply and translate
what I'm learning into a job?
Into a real-life activity.
There's a group in the college
of Optical Sciences called
Women in Optics and they
do a lot of demos, they
go out to a lot of like local
school's science nights and do
demos like "this is what
optics is, look at this cool
light experiment." And so
I started volunteering with them
and through that club I
then met a graduate student,
who then contacted me to her P.I.
who then hired me to work in
this lab.
And it gives you a community,
and one of my big things is
our retention rate
is not where it should be,
and I think thats really
important to find your
community and stay connected
because you want to get up
every day and go do the work
and be with your friends,
and be with your network.
I think what's really important
is we're recruiting new faculty
members to the university and
retaining the ones we have.
I think we have to
maybe take a different
approach to the problem,
I've been thinking about this
a little bit as with the
graduate students that you
were, for the graduate students in JPL,
they're a little bit more diverse,
I mean sometimes we have
to grow our own.
I know people are like
"oh you gotta recruit from
this school, or this school"
but we get really top students
in some of these areas,
there's no reason why as
graduate students
or undergrads like yourself,
we can't, you know, keep
in touch with you,
make sure that when you're done
that you apply back here, for
you know, and electrical engineering,
you know, we could try to get
you back after you go to
a graduate school. But also, we
could have someone in graduate
school mentor them, see if that's
what they want to do,
send them for a post-doc
to get an external experience,
but I think we have to be a little
bit more strategic in growing people,
especially now that we're
Hispanic serving.
Student success has got
to be out mantra.